[Music]
hi everybody can you hear me okay i'm
sure most of you in this audience will
have heard of dallas seen one of his
programs before so i was going to say
for those of you who don't know me what
i should say is i'm a molecular
biologist and i do a bit of science
communication so in this context i get
the best seat in the house for answering
the questions uh asking the questions to
dallas about how to communicate science
um
so first question
dallas
you should probably remember this but
like how did you first get into science
communication and broadcasting it's a
good question i i so i'm not a molecular
biologist i should i should say from the
from the outset
and in fact i'm not a scientist at all
and people are always
slightly confused i think when when they
meet me because generally when you see
science on television it's done by
scientists it's done by professor brian
cox
or it's done by professor alice roberts
or it's done by richard dawkins whoever
whoever it is generally scientists
telling you stuff i actually started
started working in like this is you know
30 years ago i actually started off
working in drama so i trained as an uh i
worked as an as an actor
uh doing drama for for for a while i
wasn't a very good actor because i was
an actor who
uh instead of reading stanislavski
and such i ended up i spent too much
time reading new scientists because i
was always really interested in science
about how the world works and how nature
works i just wasn't a scientist i'm just
in the same way that i love listening to
music but i don't play music you know
where i like watching
sport but i don't actually play the
sport but for somehow i was always
really confused that science is somehow
sort of other like why is it that if
you're interested in science people just
kind of assume you must be a scientist
anyway i was living in america at the
time
and uh i was in a bar
uh the short stop it was i remember very
clearly uh with my friend jonathan and
we were having just a discussion about
this about science and we were both
actors we both weren't involved in
science or academia at all and we were
and we had this conversation we were
like well how come why is it only
scientists get to talk about science why
you know why why
why why don't we we should do a show
rather than professor
ganesh
telling you stuff i've been promoted in
the last 10 minutes telling you all
about molecular biology why did we get
like an idiot to go and find stuff out
like a kind of bottom-up
kind of science show and this was
2003
actually early 2001 so this is a long
long time ago so anyway we came up with
this this sort of science show idea
which was and we thought well who's the
idiot well i'll do it because i'm really
bad at science i don't have any science
qualifications i failed all my science o
levels et cetera et cetera and so we did
this show
and we managed to sell it to the
discovery channel like bizarrely we were
like okay so we got to make the show for
the discovery channel and the premise of
the show was each week dallas goes on a
mission to try and do an impossible
thing and it was called dallas in
wonderland and so
so mission one was
this week i'm gonna break the men's
hundred meters record
you know and then this week i'm gonna
journey to the center of the earth and
then this week i'm gonna get abducted by
aliens and so by not being able to do
the thing each week you learn about the
thing so for example the 100 meters
episode we did you know
by me trying to do this ridiculous task
which is quite clearly i'm not going to
be able to do it but you learn all about
sport science you learn about sports
psychology you learn about biomechanics
and training and all this kind of stuff
it was actually a really good it was a
good show but we were obsessed by it was
right when the life aquatic came out you
know the the um
what who directed the life aquatic you
know
where's anderson yeah and i was really
obsessed by by that film by like the
aesthetics of that film
and bill murray in that film and i
really like the idea of just like a
bunch of idiots kind of having
adventures and you know which is what
that film is about but also it's in that
kind of wes anderson where beautifully
shot wonderful color palettes and the
music was really amazing and i remember
the the the band devo who this 80s pop
band some of you will remember diva the
the
lead singer one of the members of diva
mark mother's bag does a lot of music
and does all the music for wes
anderson's films and i was looking at
the sleeve notes of the life aquatic and
i noticed that mark mother had done the
music and i'm like we we totally want
that kind of music for our show for our
discovery show because we want it to
feel a bit like the life aquatic and i
noticed that but just by reading the
sleeve notes that he had a recording
studio just down the road from where we
were living so
you know this is on hollywood boulevard
it was the old rocky bullwinkle museum
and so i thought
[ __ ] it i'm gonna go and we drove down
there i remember knocking on the door oh
my gosh and he answered and i'm like
listen this is ridiculous we're doing
this show for discovery
we've been meeting composers but
all we've been saying is we want someone
a bit like mark mothersburg and
eventually he sort of did the music for
us love it so we were but we were a bit
arched for discovery we were a bit kind
of it was a bit what i think we were i
don't know
we got
fired after one season of doing this of
doing this thing
and we were ejected back to the uk for
being too um too i'm on guard well
i don't think we're being ivanka but
they were like they were like the
execs were like could you do like a
short week episode like it was when
discovery were all about you know they
wanted shark week every week and and we
weren't really that well dallas gets
eaten by a show so that was the answer
so that so that's kind of where it
started and then after that i came back
to the uk and then i went from there you
know having done that show and having
sort of created that idea of like idiot
tries to go on tries to find stuff out
then then i did you know stuff i joined
the bbc well
i did the gadget show for a while and
then
cool yeah i mean there's two things that
come into my mind in that there's one
thing that you talked about which is the
aesthetic of the show in itself like the
sort of quirky side of it yeah let's
park that for a second i think it sounds
an awful lot like actually the fact that
you
um
basically as a non-expert sorry
i am with it but i think that actually
might be part of the appeal it sounds
like like do you feel like that's what
you brought to these sorts of things i
think it's really important when you
know when we're talking about science
science still is seen as other people do
science so if you're not connected to
science or academia science is something
else and and i think that's well a it's
a shame because science is too
interesting just to be left for
scientists to talk about yeah and b also
it's really important for
the general populace not just to
obviously you know to be educated in
what science is and how science works
but also just because it's interesting
because science is just intrinsically an
interesting thing to talk about how the
world works how nature works why things
are the way they are the things that we
don't understand which you know for me
infinitely more interesting than the
things that we do understand and that's
like like any other form of human
culture science should be that should be
there for everyone
you know you mentioned bango's a theory
you know we got to do this family
science show on bbc one
and you know the reason i was on that
show you know we had you know academics
as well so we had lisbonnen on it and we
had jem stansfield and we had yan wong
and my role was the kind of you know
again this of every man it's like me
not being an expert asking questions i i
in a way i have the license to ask the
stupid questions because you know when
you become a professor it suddenly
becomes harder to ask the stupid
questions
but for me it's okay to answer stupid
questions yeah i mean we there's a whole
separate talk to be had about why it's
not acceptable for some people to ask
questions whereas for us but it
shouldn't be it shouldn't it shouldn't
be like that we have a really we have a
really silly culture of how we talk
about science still and our you know our
you know a whole mantra of bango's a
theory was like taking science out of
the lab and into people's lives
and actually you know giving people
permission to feel like they're allowed
to talk about science because um i think
certainly for me you know years ago i i
felt all [ __ ] science are not allowed to
come yeah that's not that's that's
something else yeah i mean you've also
talked about questions right so do you
feel like do you think what came first
do you think your curiosity about
science or the fact that once you got
into it it becomes that much like you
just there's always a white the moment
you're told any kind of scientific thing
i think
it's a good question i um i think when i
was at school doing science i just
didn't it's not that i didn't get it i
didn't want to get it because i i saw
science as the thing that those people
did
you know and i was too busy listening to
these these people yeah i was you know i
was the smiths because it was the 1980s
i was listening to smith and
science was sort of over there somewhere
and it wasn't until
i guess
probably until my early 20s i mean but
but then again you know even though
science was over there i grew up
watching bbc science i used to love
watching tomorrow's world
you know i was fascinated by that i used
to love watching like everyone i watched
david attenborough and i watched
you know connections with james burke
and you know i grew up watching you know
apollo stuff happening because i'm i'm
of that age so that was all in the
background and i found i found all that
world very interesting but i just didn't
associate it with
you know learning science i didn't want
to be a scientist yeah in the same way
that i like listening to beethoven and i
don't want to be a pianist that's okay
um
so yeah so
some i guess i think sometime in my
early 20s actually i
i chanced upon actually it was the royal
institution christmas lectures in i
think it was 91 or 92 and there was this
guy presenting it whose name was richard
dawkins
so this was a long time ago i know i
know
people's hackles will raise you know but
let's park that for a moment
but i remember richard dawkins
this young you know rather attractive
sort of professor just talking very
eloquently about evolution i never
i didn't really understand how you know
like everyone else i kind of
i sort of had a basic grasp i didn't
really understand it and he just
explained it so beautifully so so simply
so elegantly i remember watching this
christmas lecture and it was like the
windows opening in this kind of draft
coming in i was like
why did no one exp i it's so interesting
why the hell did no one tell me that
when i was
yeah i became really really fascinated
by by that and i remember reading soon
after that i read the blind watchmaker
one of his books absolutely fascinating
and then i did a i worked with the
director this guy ken campbell
and i sort of helped him on a he was
doing a series called reality on the
rocks which is like my own sort of idea
ken campbell tries to go on a mission to
try and understand quantum mechanics and
so i got really interested in the kind
of that world of crazy
stuff we don't understand and and and
and so yeah i just became really
interested in the whys and the and the
hows
house
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you